[Music]
thank you
welcome to wisdom for life where we sift
through philosophy to find practical
advice that you can use in your everyday
life hi I'm Dan Hayes I'm joined by my
co-host Dr Greg Sadler and today we're
talking about cynicism as a way of life
both ancient and modern so there's a lot
of stuff that we're going to be getting
into here we're going to introduce you
to some of the let's call them classic
cynics and and we do have to make a few
clarifications right at the start
because this is one of those
philosophical terms that we've talked
about in a number of episodes right Dan
stoicism and I don't think we've
actually tackled epicureanism in a
single episode no but
yeah anytime that we're talking about
the ancient uh eudaimonic schools from
the Greeks
um they're going to be one of those
major schools that we're trying to you
know dig into you know we did do an
episode on skepticism where we had an
interview with this guy carniades who
was a he's using the name of one of the
ancient uh skeptic authors and so the
whole point here is that cynicism in the
present doesn't mean exactly the same
thing that it meant back in ancient
times it's not totally disconnected like
um
you know equivocal terms like seal
meaning the thing that you know says or
Orton you know squeaks horns and
eats fish and stuff like that in in the
zoo and then the thing that we close
something up with that's that's where
the term has the same
sound but has no connection
um there there is a connection between
ancient and modern forms of cynicism but
there's there's a lot of differences too
yeah it's not a homophone but then there
you have that's the word yeah yeah
um but the question is Greg do you
really believe that or you're just
saying that
so you're trying to bring in modern
cynicism performatively right
if I yes I am and so yeah um we're going
to we'll talk about what it was as an
ancient school and how you know that has
been I don't know I don't know if it's
the right word is corrupted or just you
know
um as language yeah moves it it moves in
interesting and new ways that are not
really ever intended by the original use
I mean I think that's a really
interesting point to bring up so I'd
kind of like to linger over it if you if
you take the perspective that like
everything ancient is great and modern
stuff is crap and it's all degeneration
there's a lot of people in our
contemporary culture who weirdly enough
even though they're using hyper modern
ways of saying this you know like uh
saying it on Twitter or through
Instagram and all these pictures there's
a lot of people who are saying that in
the present
um I I kind of I I don't like that idea
I want to say there's two legitimate
equally legitimate uses of the term what
do you what's your take on that
it reminds me of like the the
Renaissance period And everyone's like
you know finding all these new things
it's like oh yes it was they had this
great perfect society and and we need to
like replicate that as much as possible
and you know everything has its just
attractions like at the time that we're
talking about with the ancient uh cynics
and Stokes and uh everyone at the time
they're they're vying for with their own
ideas and they're disagreeing it's not
like they're in lockstep with each other
um and this is also not the only society
that is um doing really interesting
things in the world you've got the
people in on the the Indus valleys
you've got people out in the Indian
subcontinent you get people out in China
they're all doing their own philosophy
their own creating their own things so
okay so if if oldness makes it good then
which one of the old ones is the good
one oh that's that's a great uh
technique to bring in right rather than
just saying okay fine we'll grant you
that Antiquity makes it good or makes it
preferable there's multiple Antiquities
that we can look to
yeah oh also I didn't even say about
like you know sub-Saharan Africa had
some very interesting thinkers in the
whole yeah
from a very different world as well as I
guess if you can even go to
um the Americas and the you know the
natives uh herein on having
modes of thought and and whole you know
religions as well as like uh ethics that
are you know slightly different from us
at least in our mind I mean I think so
there's like we call these the big
questions when we talk about philosophy
right and it's a little bit easy to get
jaded with bringing those in but I think
there's really uh something to this
there are certain fundamental we don't
have to call them questions let's call
them issues or problems or conundrums
that are always going to be facing
people when they reach a certain level
of development and among them are like
political ones like who should be in
charge and how should power be shared
and and what's the basis for that or
aesthetic ones like well what's what's
attractive and what's not and how do we
figure out how to make good art but then
you know the in between those two is the
ethical domain which is uh you know
incredibly important how should we live
what what good should we Orient
ourselves around and since we have you
know the same bodies
I think there's the same kinds of goods
that we get attracted to and not just
you know things in terms of bodily
Pleasures like every society figures out
how to ferment something or get high on
something and you can indulge too much
in that right
um and and burn yourself out uh and you
know everybody every society so long is
not suffering famine has issues with how
much you should eat or how much you
shouldn't or what should your attitude
towards food be or sex or laying around
in the Sun or stuff like that but uh
we're also creatures that you know
seem to Crave social approval and
relationships and Prestige and power and
and you see the same you don't see the
same Solutions or the same formulations
coming up in society after Society but
you do see the same problems getting
getting posed within each Society
right
um and one of those was
the ancient cynics here and so yeah what
are they who are they and um where do
they come from
well you know so here's where we get
into a little bit of controversy and and
actually there's going to be a whole
bunch of different controversies right
so there's a scholarly controversy that
that developed in the last say 100 years
maybe maybe a little bit 150 going back
further and the traditional story was
that
you have this guy Socrates who we know
you know mostly As like the teacher of
Plato but he actually was a teacher of a
whole bunch of people and
um
people took different things from the
guy so there was this other guy who's
younger than Socrates uh I think a
little bit older than Plato if I
remember right though whose name is
antisthenes and he's you know he's an
Athenian guy and he's credited as being
the first cynic so he's taking stuff
that he's getting from Socrates about
you know virtue being the only true good
or we need to be free of The Temptations
and addictions to Pleasures or you know
matters like that and he starts living a
certain kind of life and teaching and we
we learn about him through another
Socratic guy he's xenophon uh also known
as a you know important military
commander and kind of General badass and
uh antisthenes
um you know he he gets to say a few
things we don't have anything that he
actually wrote unfortunately but
um
you know he's he's credited as being
like the first cynic but not as being as
fully developed as cynic as the second
guy who so here's where the controversy
arises there's this guy diogenes of
synop he's an outsider he uh he actually
comes from a bad family so they get in
trouble for debasing the currency
whatever that means go go ahead yo guys
gonna ask it's like what what is the
base in the currency mean
well there's there's controversy about
that as well it could mean like uh
taking the coins and shaving off you
know
um the sides so they don't weigh what
they're supposed to weigh or maybe
filling them with something that's not
pure silver or gold or whatever but it
can also mean like scratching the face
off of it so that you can't recognize
what it is
um but anyway diogenes he is he's a
crazy guy they call him a Socrates gone
mad that's actually what Plato's
supposed to have said about him
and well yeah we're gonna get into some
stories yeah yeah yeah okay so
um
he I mean there's lots and lots there's
more stories about him than any other
cynic altogether and again he's supposed
to have written some things and he's
supposed to have taught some people and
he may or have studied with antisthenes
or he might have been kind of a
self-starter and so Scholars debate
about this and myself I don't have a
position I I've looked at the arguments
you know on on both sides and I think we
don't really know you know there's good
arguments that can be made for for
either way it's kind of trendy these
days to say oh anticipants he wasn't
really the cynic it was more diogenes
starting the the thing off so there's no
real Socratic connection but we don't
really know you know it's
you can make even an argument along the
lines of like
um if you're gonna say that saying it's
like okay uh who is the real father of
stoicism is it Xeno or is it like
chrysippus you know because logic didn't
get like fully into it until precipice
and if those are your three pillars of
Ethics physics and uh logic then it's
not fully developed then you know oh no
you know I I wouldn't say that
um it's not that actually it's it's
anticities yeah I mean I I guess I kind
of split the difference where I I
because and and there are ancient
precedents for doing this we're saying
okay so antisthenes gets the ball
rolling but he doesn't have it fully
worked out sort of like Zeno as you were
pointing out and then he's got this
person who may or may not have been a
student but certainly was aware of him
because I mean Athens is at that time is
a small town and if diogenes was doing
all the crazy stuff he was doing
somebody would have pointed out to him
surely wow what you're doing looks a lot
like what antistanes was suggesting
right and then diogenes develops it
further and it appears that diogenes
wasn't just a crazy guy going around you
know saying stuff to people he actually
had like a whole set of ideas in mind
that that we call cynicism
um and we know that he taught some
people because then the next really
important guys this person crates and
krates teaches Zeno so cynicism begets
stoicism and krates is a little bit
different than diogenes
um he's known the word that they use for
him over and over again is philanthropia
which means love of human beings we get
philanthropy from from that and he's uh
he's kind of unusual in that he's a
married cynic
like this is also interesting because
this is one of our first experiences of
a well-known female philosopher and
that's right yeah yeah
so hypatia of Alexandria
is no no this she's a different one
coming much later this is hipparchia oh
hipparchia sorry yeah and she's she's in
Athens um and her brother Metro Doris if
I remember right I might be mixing them
up with the Epicurean guy though so
anyway an M guy he he's a student of
krates and he uh here's the story
um he farts in public and I guess that
was a bad thing to do back then just
like it is you know in a lot of cases
today like you don't do it in an
elevator you don't do it when you're up
at the podium giving a presentation
right
um when you're uh saying about to say I
do in a wedding not a good time to pass
gas so anyway he was so embarrassed he
like went into his house and shut
himself up and so krates came in and
he's like man there's nothing unnatural
about this and then I guess he let a
couple rip and he's like see I do it too
you know and then hipparchia is is his
brother and she's you know she's
supposed to get married like a good
Athenian woman but she doesn't want to
marry any of the guys that are proposing
to her that her family's putting forth
and she meets karates and she's like
that's the guy I want to marry and and
you might say well what the hell's wrong
with her you know well you know cynicism
was a philosophy she she liked his
intellect she liked his way of life
she's she's into what he's doing and so
um he you know she's saying I'll only
marry this guy and he's like lady you're
nuts you know the lifestyle I live it's
not not for ladies you know and she's
like no no I can do that too and this is
another cool thing about the cynics men
and women are equally capable of of
living a virtuous life and so he like
you know according to the legend strips
he takes his stuff off again you know
very scandalous to do right he's like
this is your bridegroom you want this
guy and she's like
sold
uh and you didn't make a slight typo
there it's metrically please there you
go yeah yeah
um
but yeah this is you know comes back to
some of these like basic ideas that uh
you know from uh and uh in Essences that
you know uh
of the things that we know both from
like xenophon's
um
yeah Symposium yeah as well as from
dioges Laertes so you've got uh you know
virtue is is teachable but especially if
you're going to go to uh love because
you know the
um
that uh book The the Symposium is
talking about what is love and so he's
he's talking about like that a
um wise person will marry
um as well as
um of the wise person knows who are
worthy of love and so does not disdain
to love
um which is you know in uh congruence
with what crates and yeah I will say
there is something in xenophon Symposium
which is which is a little bit different
than than Plato's uh that anticity says
that I I really get a kick out of
actually two things and they're both
closely connected to each other
so antithenes actually has a house but
it's a crappy house and he he goes into
it and and he says
um I sleep with women and I sleep with
ugly women because
um they're not going to turn me down and
they're very grateful and so he's like
you know I may as well make things easy
for myself and you know have some some
enjoyment and then we don't get too
attached and all that and then at that
very Symposium they're drinking really
really good wine like I forget exactly
what the wine was called but it's like
the second best that you can get so
super expensive and somebody was giving
antithenees kind of a hard time about
that and he's and his response was when
I'm at home I drink the cheap stuff you
know and I don't drink a lot of it
because I want to be temperate
um but because I'm not
um I'm not addicted I'm not like a
captive to the the pleasure of drinking
wine I can actually enjoy myself with
this really really good wine and I won't
drink too much and I can have it today
and then you know if I don't have it
tomorrow I'm not going to be craving it
you know and so I thought I thought that
was kind of a cool idea with with going
back to karates and hipparchia they
actually like the Beatles said do it in
the road you know
um and so you know they they this
shamelessness is is really something
that's Central to the the cynics
yes sir it's Shameless the you know it's
only a Shameless in response to what the
the people around them think is correct
to do and so they're in doing this and
having you know maybe
um this bad reputation because they do
not conform to the uh social conventions
of the people around them they are in
fact trying to
um exemplify what is actually good yeah
and what is actually good too
yes yes natural and good
um is like the uh The stoics Virtue
virtue is this all good in both of these
I know that we jumped over diogenes and
I could see that you were on the verge
of saying some of the scandalous things
so maybe you want to run through those
since we're talking about doing things
that are not so uh socially approved in
public
well the first thing I want to do is
bring up that
um I don't know if you you want to say
that Plato and agencies are beefing or
are they just like oh playful it feels
like they're beefing
um uh yeah I I I don't think that
diogenes is just poking gentle fun at
Plato I think he's messing with him and
so for example like enjoy it much no not
really so for example like um what is it
Plato has a um an argument of what a man
is a um uh a hairless uh two biped I
want to say this biped featherless biped
and so uh this gets to the agnies he's
like oh yeah and so mine's a chicken
plucks it goes into you know whatever uh
Plato is hanging out with is
um friends talking velocity and goes
behold Plato's mad yeah a plucked
chicken
um but he's constantly you know poking
at him and uh doing things that are you
know outside of the normal context other
ones are on like he's called the agenise
the dog because he acts like a dogwood
he
um when he needs to relieve himself he
relieves himself up to the point where
people are like calling him a dog and
he'll go over and pee on them just like
a dog would
yeah it actually says in diogenes
Laertes he like lifts his leg like a dog
does you know
um and speaking of chickens there was a
bit of choking of the chicken right yes
yeah you know as I said like whatever
um felt good was natural for uh the
human to do he would do and so when the
the moment arose uh you know in the
middle of the street would uh rub one
out
yeah and then there's a line that goes
longer that I'm going to try to remember
it exactly he gets people criticize him
they're like you shouldn't be doing that
man and he says if only it was so easy
to appease hunger by rubbing your belly
so there's rubbing involved in both
cases you know all right but I mean
that's typical biogenes right right and
like you know if it's true or not
there's the famous story of him meeting
Alexander the Great right yeah uh you
know Alexander comes by and he's heard
so much about this guy dodging cynic
um comes to Athens and sees him he's
literally living in an old wine cask
um and he's he's working on something
and you know uh Alexander walks up with
his retinue and he goes like oh
um you know I'm I'm the biggest guy
around I'm King I'm conquering all these
things
um but I hear about you what can I do
for you and he goes let's get out of my
light
I was like I can offer you anything it's
like nope and he responds to him he's
like man if I were not Alexander
I would be diogenes and diogenese
response if I were not diogenes I would
be diagonist well I mean what is
displaying there is is a whole bunch of
different cynic values of Freedom you
know being able to tell like the
top guy in the world at least the Greek
World
um
you're blocking my son buddy you know to
frankness of speech is often how it's
talked about parasia in Greek being able
to say what's on your mind and they
really did value that and I think that
they they thought that there was
something special about diogenes but
he's he's saying hey any one of you can
do this you just got to be willing to
pay the price for it
and and part of that price was you know
severe asceticism yeah getting rid of
anything that you know uh could hold you
down
um the idea is like you you don't have
these physical attachments to yourself
because virtue is the only good is so
good is that what is actually necessary
for you to have a good and flourishing
life and that if you need other things
then that is actually potentially a
hindrance and so there's a story about
him
um going to the river and he's got his
cup and he's going to dip it into the
river to get get a drink of water and he
sees a little boy cup his hands and fill
his hands and it's like oh dang he's out
doing me and throws away his cup yeah I
mean the traditional cynic outfit or
costume whatever you want to call it is
a staff which makes sense because you
know you're going to walk around
um you're gonna get tired but plus you
know there might be dangers you need to
beat people with it and then they would
call it a wallet but it's really much
more like a backpack or a satchel or
just stuff that you could put things in
and famously they like to carry like
lentils and lupins you know these these
super easy to cook things it's like
travel light and then a cloak and a big
cloak that you could use as a blanket as
well as like something that to hang over
your back so you're ready for the
weather at least in ancient Greece I
mean would this work in Wisconsin
no yeah I don't know
um
that um
the staff is not only just like used for
walking but it is in itself
um a yet another uh transgression
against
um what to uh have in the city center
that view on you would wear a sword and
that became gauche and see where lesser
and lesser weapons to yourself until it
got to the point by the time that the
housing is around that you don't wear
any weapons in the city anymore it's not
like custody right right and even to
have the staff is a little bit
uncivilized even though it's the the
least of the weapons I mean you know if
you got a big enough stick it's not
really a small weapon you know you can
do well the least in the idea like it's
not
um
only for military purposes multiple uses
yeah you know so we should probably talk
about
um some more of these key values and
ideas since we've we've brought them up
um and you you mentioned virtue is the
only good so we should remind ourselves
that ancient Greeks with a few
exceptions like Aristotle tended to talk
about four main virtues that we often
call the cardinal virtues and you see
them across school so Plato talks about
these the stoics the cynics
the various hedonist schools like the
epicureans and the Syrian ants they all
use this same
schema of there being wisdom you know or
practical wisdom Prudence being able to
figure stuff out what's good for us
being able to use our our brains while
Justice giving other people you know
what we owe them something social
um Temperance which we've talked about a
little bit already are moderation
self-control you know not getting drunk
all the time for example and then uh
courage and courage included things like
not just running into a burning building
but endurance being able to like put up
with I don't know mosquitoes biting you
or being too hot or too cold or being
hungry or things like that
um so that was that was you know the
idea that virtue is either you know like
the only good or the most important good
because you know you could say well what
about companionship
um I mean you probably want virtuous
companions I suppose
um right
I guess the idea is like those are
ancillary they're nice to have right
right
but they're not necessary in and of
themselves yeah they're not waiting
distracted by
or if you have to choose between virtue
and something else choose virtue
right this is definitely an in contrast
to like Aristotle was like you got the
virtues and then you've got these extra
things you also have yeah or um you know
uh the epicureans at the time where
um there's a whole bunch of nice things
to happen yeah and the virtues are for
the epicureans are basically so you can
live a pleasant life you know you need
to be thoughtful so you don't choose the
wrong Pleasures that are going to get
you pains even courage so they're like
well you need to be courageous and that
might mean going out in the battlefield
and risking getting killed precisely so
you could enjoy Pleasures you know right
um so yeah especially going back to the
endurance there's like stories about
them on holding on to statues in winter
you know to tug the statue there's a I
believe this is a story by diogenes
doing that yeah uh what a Spartan
soldier
um coming up and asking him questions
you remember that question I don't
remember that offhand but uh
um regardless but I mean the point of
that was to like make your body tougher
by subjecting it to
to the environment that you're in you
know right
doing exercise in the hot sun in the
summer
right and I think the the question is
like why are you doing that now to
um you know and improve my ability to
deal with the cold and he says is it
difficult it's like ah not really
um kind of like a very uh cynic response
to it and it's like well that's not very
impressive yeah well I mean the the
underlying thing though it's not
difficult when you've been doing it for
a long time
I mean for the ordinary person that's
that's pretty tough to do so yeah you
know one of the one of the terms that
they used a lot is we we translate it as
toil but it can also be translated as
pain uh ponos is is the Greek for that
and ponoros means you know like
difficult or um also can mean Wicked too
but you know the idea is you don't want
to be toiling and and they'll say listen
you're gonna have to toil you're gonna
have to put up with stuff you're gonna
have to like put in the work so why not
do it in a rational way you know you
could like do a lot of toiling for the
stuff that people think is good like the
big house on the hill or a ton of money
or an attractive spouse
um but that's actually going to bring
you more toil later on you know as soon
as you've got that money you got to work
to keep that money and guard it and if
you've got a attractive spouse well now
other people are going to be trying to
seduce them and and you know you might
not be up to what they require of you
for that why not just put in the good
kind of toil like hugging statues or
simplifying your life or pick whatever
else you know cultivating the virtues
why not put in that because then you'll
actually be happy and free and be able
to do what you want to do
yeah
um and
this continues on to one of the next
ones like this read Freedom or the
self-sufficiency Via you know this
asceticism yeah and if you do the toil
um and you discard the things that could
potentially you know distract you from
what is that actual good then you
um are able to act in a totally
unhindered Manner and this is also and
continues with yeah
um
turning away from social convention
yeah so we talked a little bit about
this metaphor of debasing the currency
earlier and really the way the the
cynics tended to interpret that in the
time of diogenes and karates and then
even much later because this went on for
centuries was deliberately flouting
social conventions not that all of them
necessarily are bad but you got to test
them you know you can't just assume I I
think this is a very common thing in
most societies to assume that well if it
is a convention or a norm it must be the
way I I should behave it's it's rational
for me to do that and the cynics would
say no let's actually uh think about
this
um I mean think about so many of the
things that that we do you know I'll
give you a great example from my
academic days
um I like to and I would say the first
10 15 years of teaching I would
generally wear a tie and either a suit
or a uh a coat you know a jacket and I
did so in part because I wanted to
impress upon the students because I was
teaching in a Maximum Security Prison at
the start and then I was teaching at a
struggling uh historically black college
where people sometimes the the older
instructors would be kind of
lackadaisical about what they'd wear I
wanted to impress on them that we're
doing something important in education
you know but why did I pick that outfit
because there's already a social
convention that if we're doing serious
stuff and you're a guy you wear a tie
right and then if you want to make it
extra special wear a suit or a sports
coat with dress pants
um now you know
that's not necessarily what we need to
do for everything I mean it used to be
back in the day that I mean you know
about this and neither of us know about
this from experience because this was so
long ago that you would like if you're
going to get on the plane
you gotta wear a suit you know or a
jacket and tie if you're going out to a
fancy restaurant jacket and tie you know
um definitely if you're going to a job
interview jacket and tie you know
um that one's still well it depends on
where you're at that definitely still
holds in the Midwest
yeah I think for the most
right I mean if you come in and you're
wearing shorts and flip-flops
even wearing a tie isn't going to help
you then
um wow but I mean that's that's a prime
example of something why do we do that I
mean you know originally the cravat was
supposed to like hold your shirt
together at the top and so I guess it'd
keep your neck warm or something but
none of the ties that we wear serve that
purpose anymore I mean it's it's just a
social convention and well I guess in in
the words of uh tevya tradition
tradition
um yeah it's a you know the question is
on is tradition good
inherently or is it only good because it
actually has some underlying thing that
would allow it to be good and so we you
know as you said this this
tie and jacket uh conveys a certain
thing that like you you understand and I
understand because we grew up in you
know our our society in those these
conventions yeah part of our society a
different society would have totally
different dress like we were in on you
know uh I guess China Japan you know
Korea far away from like our Western
culture you know to a certain extent
those you know ties and whatnot have
have permeated it yeah yeah at least in
the business culture you could say yeah
right
um but there's still you know other
traditional dresses that are you know
convey these same things of like the
importance and seriousness that are not
the same as ours
um so if the
whatever you're doing yeah still has to
have some underlying thing and just
because the tradition doesn't
automatically make it good
um it still could be good it just it's
not good just because you happen to be
doing it yeah I was just laughing
because I was thinking about another
thing that we've already mentioned with
the cynics which is breaking wind or
passing gas or farting I mean a lot of
people get really really bent out of
shape about this
you know natural human healthy thing to
do I mean if you're constantly Breaking
Wind you might you might want to go see
the doctor right or look at your diet or
something but
um the notion that you must not do this
you know I mean okay so you know if you
if you can hold it so you don't do it in
the elevator that's a good idea all
right all right I mean diogenes probably
would be doing it in the elevator uh
just deliberately and then saying ah see
It's Perfectly Natural but I think
karates wouldn't you know he probably
would be like hey you know uh let's
let's do this in a more well ventilated
area
interesting here we've got
um
this whole like I'm going to be kind of
in your face especially with yeah the
Dodge and he's the cynic
um
and okay in other words
example of this is he was you know out
there with a lamp in the middle of the
day and like putting it up in people's
faces it's like I'm looking for a good
man
um because he's
um to a certain extent he he wants to
engage and he wants to provoke that's
the one yeah provoke yeah uh people to
actually uh look at the preconceptions
that they have and say are these
actually good or they're just doing them
because you've been told that you ought
to do them and if you haven't actually
um engaged with the odds and what it
actually if it has any utility or not
then you're just following along you're
kind of shaping that regard you're not
actually thinking for yourself in your
minds now it's interesting because you
know we've got these like great cynics
early on in the fourth and and third
Century
um BCE and then cynicism kind of goes
into Decline and then it like re-emerges
in the first century of uh the Christian
era like in a major way like and not
just in Athens but like everywhere you
know there's uh Demetrius that Seneca
talks about there's uh Lucian of
samasota talking about these different
cynics and apparently there were lot of
people who were taking
diogenes and other cynics example as an
excuse to basically act like selfish
jerks just flouting the rules and
demanding people pay them you know give
me give me some alms and then there were
other people who are like that's not
what genuine cynicism should look like
why not well I mean it seems and it's
kind of funny because you could be like
well hey Who the hell's to say who the
right cynic is you know isn't part of
cynicism going against whatever
paradigms or Norms people put forward
and so there's a real tension there and
there's even this guy much later on
Julian the Emperor who writes this uh
discourse called to the uneducated
cynics and he's saying cynicism is
supposed to look like this and you bums
are making it look like this you know
and then what he he sketches as you know
what a good cynic would look like
it doesn't look I mean he talks about
diogenes he talks about anticines but it
doesn't look that much like them it's
supposed like they're the universal
philosopher so like clearly both of
these are are off base and and wrong you
know
um and and I think maybe part of the
clue is to you know Epictetus talks
about this in because Epictetus is a
stoic who really does like the cynics he
actually thinks that
most people shouldn't be cynics because
it's too difficult of a life so be a
stoic instead which is also difficult
but isn't quite as
tricky and he talks about the cynic as
being a Herald of cataracts of God
meaning that like the cynic has a job to
do and a really important job to like
show what a human being could be like
um and it's it's a Divine calling and so
if you use it just as license to like
beg from people on the street and not
bathe and you know uh do you know do
whatever you want to do well that's not
real cynicism for for uh people like
Epictetus or Julian
I was reading about I think at this
point in time
there's a group of people who like had
their like day job okay
um and then on the weekends would dress
up in their cynic Garb and go out and do
cynicy things
nowadays you might be awesome yeah yeah
a Civil War reenactor and so it's like
hey look you know I have to toil all
week at this thing but you know when the
weekend comes I can go out and like
pretend to be a cynic and and do all and
plow these things and uh they're LARPing
right is this is live action yeah
I mean another term that we use a lot
and this is a good sort of like lead-in
to something else we're going to talk
about modern uh equivalences to cynicism
um being just performative right you're
not really into it you're just acting
apart you know the and by the way the
word that we nowadays use as hypocrite
that comes from the word for actor back
in the ancient times and people would be
accused of being actors uh back then for
doing the sort of thing that you're
talking about
that's interesting because we're going
to get into the modern portion of it and
maybe we'll just have the transition
right now and where one of the main
ideas and the difference between the
ancient and modern is that you are
making this assertion that everyone's
just an actor everyone's in Hypocrites
yeah that is doesn't actually believe
anything that has has no grounding
except for just kind of like a base you
know Primal like uh pettigreed and you
know
um purely uh hedonic desires and that is
the thing is actually and everything
above it is just
you know dressing all right a costume
that one puts on and or your you know
modern day Tartus yeah I mean what they
have in common with the ancient cynics
is saying that the social conventions
that we have
shouldn't really be given the Authority
or weight that um we do grant them you
know um
because they're not natural they're not
they're not based in anything
that's true to human nature or leading
us to Virtue but I think the modern
cynics are often saying nobody's
virtuous you can't be virtuous if you're
pretending to be you're full of crap you
know
um and and oftentimes they'll still
justify it by saying yeah man I'm just
like the rest of you I'm I'm just you
know as we used to say back in the day
holding the mirror up to society man you
know like like uh I I'm I'm not claiming
to be any any better I'm not claiming to
be a diogenes or a karates to have
virtue I'm just saying that we're all a
bunch of Hypocrites you know
and so you can see the you know when
you're young or when you're playing
around with it right yeah yeah and you
can definitely see how
this at least portions of this uh
ancient Civic philosophy you could morph
or be corrupted into this more nuanced
thing of like yo Dodges is going around
and he's like doing all the things that
are just counter uh what everyone thinks
ought to be done yeah and trying to show
off
um like their uh potential hypocrisy
um
but it doesn't actually have anything
that is grounded in itself Asian cynics
are are thinking like what is it
actually to be a good person what what
are the things that are actually of
value and uh the the modern one is there
is nothing about you everyone is lying
everyone is a phony
yeah and it makes you think that the
modern sense of cynicism in this way
it's not exactly the same thing but it
kind of like it's a neighbor to nihilism
this this overarching nothing has any
sort of meaning value I mean the cynic
often will still say well I'm exercising
my freedom of speech or I should uh you
know tell people when they're being
Hypocrites but you can say well why I
mean what good is coming out of it by by
doing so if there's no path forward to
something
better
than you know how are you making
anything
[Music]
um how are you leading towards towards
something for for people and you can say
well there's there's a certain good in
like realizing what a scumbag you are
well I don't know if that's the case I
mean certainly if like you look at
yourself and you're like oh man I need
to work on myself I need to develop you
know these virtues over here that
actually exist that are live
possibilities but if it's just um yeah I
should realize what a I'm a phony and
like all the rest of the phonies
it's like I I'm a scumbag so I'm gonna
go and I'm
a pig trough over there and you know
just get all dirty and just like a revel
go to the buffet and just stuff stuff in
my pockets yeah
the what's it called like the the
negative nihilism before you get to the
positive nihilism that like you know to
build some sort of value
um instead you're just like yeah nothing
matters thus nothing matters and I'm not
going to try to build anything
um
and it's a
I don't know
I don't know how you could stay in that
place too long it seems well I mean
that's just self-destructible and when
we talk about people being cynical in
the present we really do I think that
that that self-destructiveness or at
least self-lacerating
that's kind of part of it isn't it it's
it's directed towards others hey all
these other people are phonies none of
them are what they pretend to be none of
them are in touch with whatever could be
genuine you know values or the proper
way to live
um but it's also turned inward on the
the individual person who's making those
those criticisms too
it could be at least for some I'm not
going to say it for all
um just a coping mechanism too okay well
uh yeah if everyone else sucks then I
don't have to work on myself
I think you're right about that I think
that in a lot of cases people who are
being cynical and they don't necessarily
even have to use the word cynical it can
be just sort of the the displayed
attitude are uh often like that and it
could be because of we could think about
trauma you know getting people stuck in
in kind of a rot or what if everybody
around you really are a bunch of phonies
you know I mean how do you find your way
past that you know
yeah it's
so if if even if everyone around you are
ponies does that mean that you should
also wallow with them or is there some
you know project that you can Endeavor
upon yourself yeah I mean to be fair
there are some contemporary people in
the present who do in fact call
themselves cynics and look back to
ancient cynicism so there's a Facebook
group called The kunosargas which is you
know uh supposedly the place where
cynicism was taught in Athens we don't
really know if that was the case or not
um and then there's other communities
and groups and there are people who
tried you know they swap cynic practices
and they read the ancient stuff and they
encourage each other
um you know one of the things that was a
a recent like contest was making lentil
soup because lentils are you know very
easy to transport right and they're very
cheap and you can make a good good
hearty soup with them that's quite
nourishing and so there were all these
recipes out there and then uh it turned
kind of funny because some people like
their recipes were too elaborate and
then other people would be like that's
not properly cynic you know and maybe
they're right about that you know but I
I think there is a different movement
that doesn't call itself cynicism
and it's not and it's not cynicism it's
not ancient cynicism but it Bears some
resemblances to it which is this notion
of minimalism
of reducing your possessions and your
needs and desires to what's most
reasonable and there's you know you can
if you Google it you can find all sorts
of cool stuff there's blogs and books
and things like that
I kind of think that somebody who now
she's not a cynic as such I'm not
claiming that but is kind of aligned
with them is Marie condo you know she
had that book
um I forget exactly do you remember the
title of it oh on the like the magical
power of tidying things up I think
that's yeah so and something along that
and it was just about like you know
making sure that you don't have too much
crap I mean I don't agree with her that
you should only have I think she said 50
books total obviously I I have to have
more books than that uh yeah
but you know that whole like process of
thinking have you used this thing you
know does it spark Joy meaning I mean
that's kind of a new agey way of saying
does this do I get any value out of this
this thing and if not uh letting it go
you know
uh
I see also people that take this way too
far and you know there there is a like
some things don't spark Joy but um it's
going to save me a lot of money if I
still have it in a year when I need it
for it's a particular use again
I mean that could be Joy deferred right
right I guess there's um kind of a a
polemic against these people that is
Extreme minimal yes yeah and it's like
you have to at least in our society have
a well enough paying job that you can
um at the drop of the Hat
um buy the thing that you need or
um or rent it or whatever
um in a way that you can uh because a
lot of them is like oh you should be
totally living this like regular
lifestyle like you know a regular job
whatnot just get rid of all your stuff
your stuff is like cluttering up your
life yeah um but but a lot of times
they're like oh well then I needed a you
know
a coffee machine I had already got rid
of my coffee machine so I just went and
bought a new one and it
this is interesting place where you have
to be constantly buying things and
getting rid of them or so you're how
renting them you're just participating
in the market economy in a different
modality right one that allows us to say
that and think that you're better than
other people in this respect
right and so if you're actually going to
do this and say like I don't need these
things and I'm just going to remove them
from my life
um and like well I don't I I'm not going
to have a coffee machine and therefore
I'm not making coffee ever again sure
maybe you're gonna do that
yeah you know I so this is way way back
you know we use a French press uh rather
than like a drip coffee or something
like that
and we didn't have a you know like a
replacement I think they call it a
sleeve the glass thing that's going in
the the framework and I'm pretty clumsy
I I'm pretty rough on my possessions and
somehow I cracked it you know I think I
actually I like cocked it with a coffee
cup or something like that
and it broke you know and then we were
living right next to our landlords at
the time and I went over and I was like
ah this is crappy where where do you
think do I have to like walk into town
to get myself a new uh French Press
thing and our landlord said oh I've got
a extra one you know I bought one a
while back I'll just let you have this
one you know and it's a good thing he
was a little bit of a hoarder right
I benefited as somebody who was kind of
attracted to minimalism not with books
obviously but with other stuff
um by the fact that this other person
wasn't embracing that lifestyle but was
embracing a different one also to say
too with Marie kondo so she got some
Flack lately because she's had three
kids and apparently she doesn't keep as
tidy of a house and people were saying
oh I see you're a hypocrite you don't
live up to the stuff in your book and
then her answer was I've got three kids
you know let's be realistic about this
sort of thing I don't have to follow
this all the time which to me shows a
greater analogy to cynicism being
willing to say first of all yes this is
the reality and
um I can be free even of these norms
right you know
that's a
I don't know like is it hypocritical or
it was did she ever say like oh everyone
has to do this forever but if you're
trying to tidy up here here is a method
to do that yes it was more it was more
the second it was hey this is a way to
make your life better I'm not telling
you it's it's not a you know this is the
categorical imperative you must obey
this or something like that you know
now
so uh yes maybe we should hit some of
these uh practices
yeah I mean we've mentioned a few of
these things like making and eating
lentil soup you know I mean and that
could be anything it could be baking
your own bread being somewhat
independent of
the the grocery store I mean you're
still buying your raw materials at the
at the grocery store you're not going
out and harvesting the lentils yourself
right
um but you don't have to like build get
the the pre-made lentil soup in the can
right yeah
um there's something satisfying about
making your own food too I I find
um and then you know yeah we talked
about breaking with social conventions
but if you wanted so a lot of these
these we came up with like a whole list
that we're not going to get to maybe
we'll do a follow-up uh down the line
sometime a lot of these came from a
class that I'm just finishing up
teaching at Milwaukee Institute of Art
and Design for I think the third or
fourth time called philosophy
mindfulness in life and it's really
about philosophies as ways of life so we
look at epicureanism and stoicism and
cynicism and these all involve practices
like doing things so breaking with
social conventions I suggested that my
students should actually like pick a
social convention that they actually buy
into right now and deliberately break it
and see what happens does the world come
apart you know is the embarrassment too
great and they have to go hide
themselves out of Shame you know or do
things turn out to be okay by
breaking it do you have any good
examples
um
I mean it's been a long time since I
looked at their reports but
um I do remember you know like it did
make some of them Bolder and dealing
with their major professors not not
people like me that they happen to take
classes with but the people that kind of
control their fate you know and there's
a lot of deference that's that's given
uh to professors and you know realizing
that that's just a social convention
um can be kind of helpful for some of
the students that are a little anxious
or shy or stuff like that
one that I've been meaning to do is like
um like wear a onesie to the mall
[Laughter]
you know because it's totally off topic
I've been re-watching the show what for
I think the third or fourth time the
Venture Brothers which is just a
wonderful cartoon and just the last uh
couple episodes
um Dr Venture Rusty Venture takes his
son the the son who's like the smart one
who he identifies with Dean Taylor and
oh yes he's getting him yeah he calls it
a speed suit he says don't you call it a
onesie
but everybody else around him calls it a
yes all the difference there's there's
like a belt loop and like a pocket that
you put your uh pens in you know all
right
um yeah absolutely lovely episode lovely
TV show I'll give you an example of that
from Antiquity so we mentioned you know
Zeno the father founder of stoicism he
studied with krates so krates gave him a
bowl of lentil soup that he was supposed
to carry across the marketplace and I
guess it was like somehow shameful to
bring food into the marketplace if it
was you know something like that and
well like Dodgers like was doing that as
well he'd be like eating in the
marketplace and I was like oh my gosh
yeah I I don't know why because I think
they also sold food in the marketplace
but right anyway he um he tried to hide
it under his cloak and karates then hits
him with the staff which breaks the bull
now there's like lentils everywhere and
like you know um Xeno runs away but what
he was trying to do is get Zeno just to
like be more uh comfortable with
breaking conventions you know yeah so
interestingly it that might have been
like a reason why he's like I'm not
gonna actually follow the cynics I'm
Gonna Go My Own Way because he had such
a negative reaction to you know dealing
with this uh potential you know
embarrassment embarrassment yes well I I
think we we might have to ramp up uh
shortly I will just mention very very
briefly one of the really great works
that you can find uh that covers a lot
of this stuff is by Ann Scott Allen it's
fairly recent it's just called cynicism
and you you can easily get it do you
want to lead us out on a final thought
yeah so we're gonna leave you with the
words of antistanes
wealth and poverty do not lie in a
person's state but at their souls
[Music]
foreign